our cloud journey started with
bare-metal services for everything we
started off by migrating services to
what's called via size virtualized
instances after that we made the journey
over to kubernetes we have almost 40
micro services under our belt and
kubernetes helps us orchestrate and
manage those services moving to a micro
services architecture without kubernetes
would have been a nightmare the amount
of manpower required to maintain and
service that infrastructure would be
magnitudes higher than we currently have
in terms of our staff as we switched to
kubernetes what happened was the
developers began to take control of how
applications were configured and how
pipelines were built out that actually
gave us a lot of efficiencies because it
took workload off of the operations
teams plate and it put it on to the
developers plate which actually created
a synergy and that synergy was that
instead of us having to rely on a
separate team to do configuration
management the developers were able to
figure out what that app needed in terms
of resources and they can build their
own docker files and what they ran
locally on their machine was what was
deployed out to the cloud with manage
kubernetes we've been able to create
environments within minutes we can build
up a new cluster we can configure it and
we can give a team that needs an
integration environment the services
they need and in isolated region we can
continue our work as a development team
on building other features or our
customers require so we can break things
without the fear that we're tearing up
someone else's integration environment
that's some functionality that we never
had before kubernetes has greatly
improved our velocity in terms of
spinning up data centers what used to
take us a month to spend up an entire
data center we can now do within 24
hours steel house chose Sto as our
service mesh for several reasons the
security that it provides and the
ability to do retry logic on HTTP
requests sto providing retry logic
without us having to modify our code is
a huge benefit
the big benefits we've seen from our
cloud strategy have been our abilities
to move faster develop and deploy
quicker and have better insight into our
applications and to do all this with a
better SLA because we were able to
leverage our cloud providers manage
services that allows our team to seem
bigger than it is
you